Карантин розбрату. Регіони, які опинилися у "червоній" зоні
через високий рівень епідемічної небезпеки поширення COVID-19,
не хочуть виконувати рішення центру.
Київ проти Луцька і Тернополя. Чи мають право міста відмовитися і не посилювати карантин?
Урядова комісія з питань техногенно-екологічної безпеки та надзвичайних ситуацій визначила,
що Луцьк, Тернопіль та Кіцманський район Чернівецької області
мають бути у так званій "червоній" зоні, де будуть діяти
найжорсткіші обмеження через пандемію коронавірусу.
Близькі до неї Львів, Бережани та ще декілька регіонів у західних областях.
Вони - в "помаранчевій" зоні.
Місцева влада Луцька і Тернополя вважає, що таке рішення уряду
суперечить Конституції України, і не хоче запроваджувати обмеження.
Адже йдеться про поновлення заборони роботи громадського транспорту, кафе і ресторанів,
дитячих садків, торгово-розважальних центрів, готелів та інших закладів.
Люди залишаться без роботи, бізнес зазнає збитків, а бюджет
матиме значні недонадходження, скаржиться місцева влада.
У відповідь центральна влада погрожує відповідальністю.
Що буде за невиконання рішень з центру, достеменно не знають ані в Києві,
ані в Луцьку та Тернополі. За словами заступника глави МВС Антона Геращенка,
мери, які (цитата) займаються популізмом, відповідатимуть
за кожного загиблого у своїх містах.
Мовляв, можуть бути порушені кримінальні справи проти представників місцевої влади.
Утім, довести в суді причинно-наслідкові зв’язки
між конкретною смертю внаслідок ускладнень від коронавірусу та діями
чи бездіяльністю чиновників буде вкрай складно.
Крім того, за тиждень ситуація може змінитися,
місто чи район вже не будуть у "червоній" зоні, і справа, відповідно, розвалиться в суді.
Інші санкції за невиконання рішення урядової комісії - штрафи.
Поліція має складати протоколи на перевізників та власників бізнесу,
які продовжуватимуть працювати у "червоній" зоні.
25 жовтня цього року в Україні заплановані місцеві вибори.
У боротьбі за голоси виборців активно використовується і тема карантину,
який набрид і дратує багатьох людей.
Одні політики спекулюють на захисті населення і порятунку життя,
інші - на послабленні протиепідемічних обмежень для збереження робочих місць.
Поки Луцьк і Тернопіль у "червоній" зоні, там не зупинятимуться поїзди далекого сполучення.
Відповідне рішення на виконання урядових постанов
та рішень обласних регіональних комісій з питань техногенно-екологічної безпеки
та надзвичайних ситуацій вже ухвалила "Укрзалізниця".
Мер Тернополя закликає не гнівити людей і не влаштовувати транспортну блокаду.
За словами Сергія Надала, "така блoкада міста була хіба що за часів татар".
У Мінохоронздоров’я зазначають, що влада на місцях
згідно з законодавством не може самостійно послаблювати карантинні обмеження.
Це може робити тільки уряд, а регіональна влада -
лише посилювати карантинні заходи, якщо в цьому є потреба.
Щоб визначити, до якої зони належить регіон,
застосовують 4 показники, спираючись на досвід країн ЄС.
Це завантаженість лікарень. Має бути зайнято не більше 50 відсотків ліжко-місць.
Крім того, враховуються середня кількість проведених тестів,
коефіцієнт виявлення випадків інфікування та показник динаміки зростання
випадків інфікування, який має бути не більше 10 відсотків.
З огляду на такі критерії багатьох дивує, що Київ
попри приріст нових випадків COVID-19 опинився у "зеленій" зоні.
Втім, за словами головного санітарного лікаря Віктора Ляшка,
наразі столиця не має перевищення показників 5 днів поспіль.
Якщо ж це таки станеться, то і Київ може опинитися
в наступній за ступенем небезпеки зоні.
Засідання урядової комісії, яка аналізує рівень розповсюдження коронавірусу,
відбуватиметься щоп'ятниці, а нові зони запроваджуватимуться щопонеділка.